it's the last week of so by October I
know it's been rough for a lot of people
eating he does
there you go sober October greetings
from podcast Ville the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by
athletic greens
you've got like Joey what that's let it
greens it's an awesome supplement that
gives you big dick swinging energy
listen guys if you're not starting your
day off for the blast of vitamins you
already went down the [ __ ] tubes go
back to bed but if you want to feel
tip-top Magoo let aesthetic greens do
the dirty work they got you covered in
all five critical areas health energy
immunity gut health and hormonal support
who else
takes care you like that no body
[ __ ] in right now members of the
church family got a special offer twenty
free travel packs valued at $79 your
first purchase do me a favor jump over
to athletic greens dot-com / sure to get
your travel facts today that's athletic
greens dot-com / Church and before you
do this watch the movie changing the
game on Netflix let me know what you
[ __ ] think it's pretty crazy you'll
see if you don't need your greens or not
the church is also brought to you by CBD
lies let me explain something yesterday
got on stage and no one gets [ __ ] in
one went back to my room alarm at 3:30
car it for playing at 6:00 landed at
9:00 drove myself home [ __ ] got home
wash my [ __ ] did a little light workout
just to get the sodium out hit the bag
under the Sun couple swings in the
kettlebell [ __ ] went to an eye a
script writing class and then went back
home and home with the family why CBD
lie and Doc Tom that's [ __ ] why okay
whether it's the the gummy bears the the
tension under your tongue listen they're
the best out there how do I know because
I'm [ __ ] a limited at fifty-six so do
yourself a favor
CBD line that time right now impressing
church and get 20% off your first
daughter number two listen it's Monday
already you blew it this [ __ ] weekend
by not betting [ __ ] Houston alright
my bookie calm is here my bookie got AG
of course
listen you we do this to make money
nobody's gambling so you go to the bar
and tell your friends how cool you are
at the end of the day it's about net
[ __ ] winners okay listen you
pet you you you didn't bet [ __ ]
Michigan against Notre Dame you didn't
bet [ __ ] Houston you didn't do a lot
of things you were supposed to do and
you could have made some easy money
my bookie ballet G coz listening way
you're betting is just as important this
who you're bettin on if you're trying to
bet on the NFL baseball UFC MMA Bellator
whatever the [ __ ] you want my bookies
gotta plus they got something your
bookie ain't got side bets prop bets you
can switch your bet at the kickball I
mean listen do you know you can bet on
games out to kickoff if you if by the
second half it looks like your bets
gonna lose you can always take the other
side your bookie let you do that no so
do me a favor go to my bookie dial a G
double your first deposit right now use
promo code Church your hundred percent
bonus and your initial deposit up to
$1,000 all right I'm taking care of you
today that's it it's [ __ ] November
that's it yeah Halloween's there's a
tricky tricky and you're still walking
around with rabid [ __ ] pockets cut
this [ __ ] listen every week you're
packed you bet yourself three four net
when is on Laos who's better than you
you're gonna walk away with a little
salary even if it's 1200 you pick up a
couple people on uber you got yourself
nobody knows nothing you're under the
radar you sell a couple pills to people
you're ready to go listen my bookie that
AG today is the way to go and don't
forget our promo code this church CH you
are CH when creating your account to
claim your bonuses and you play your
when you get paid that's my bookie that
age you pick this [ __ ] me Lisa
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what you
gotta get that [ __ ] blood bouncing
you know whether you have Spanish blood
not one of your grandmother's fun sucked
the Spanish that got one time or another
stop kidding yourself it's a chore -
what's happened now we're coming out the
gate on a Tuesday morning for starters I
want to thank if you came to the stress
factory in New Brunswick this week and
you [ __ ] were off the chain
if cameras were there [ __ ] everybody
would have a great special but that's
what made it better no cameras over
there no nothing just you savages it was
great to see my family it was great to
see kids and I was 15 with you know we
talked about robbing a van and we did a
bunch of [ __ ] so you just said I loved
it one of my friends shows up he sits in
the front row now you guys can ask him
if what the [ __ ] I'm talking about is
true and this kid was right he didn't
live next door to me he live next door
the next door okay
so him and I and his brother God rest
his soul
we [ __ ] ran together every day and he
used to have a lot of acne and I'm him
one day he had a pimple above his lip
okay and it was a white head with a
black head in it oh can he bit into a
hamburger and the pimple you'll never
forget that all as long as I could look
to be a hundred eighty oh god and I
still remember that pimple bust him like
a little package of mustard on his hat
and he just cuz you didn't know it that
little mustard seed
I like 40 years later he still can't
live it down I didn't say it didn't look
great he that was in and out
it looked [ __ ] tremendous and if his
skin look tremendous but at that time we
don't swarm otherwise they would call I
don't even know but he used to be funny
like he was a naturally funny guy and we
had a kid that had big ears and I
remember one who was sitting there was
stoned to the gills and the kid was very
sensitive and everybody would call him
biggie isn't even lose his mind
and my friend this kid Michael was doing
something I saw him take two albums out
of their covers like two regular night
you know that you put on a photograph
right they took a newspaper and he
opened it up so it was like a newspaper
with us album cover on this and an album
on this side and he goes who am i
Sabatino reading the paper let me tell
you something [ __ ] died
after but I told the story about my
first meet to experience a which I had
never told before it happened in 1979 so
you can't press charges
what what happened tell us come on me
him Carlos Perez Dominic specialis other
kid my mother wasn't home and we got
[ __ ] up I'm a crystal THC aka angel
dust divided by the square-root divided
by the square-root we drank a bunch of
[ __ ] we drank like a case of nips okay
in an hour and a half that's eight years
of peace I was like five of us we drank
like nine or ten beers yeah we did like
to pint the southern comfort we were
fellas up and we smoked a bunch of dope
they were going to a party but I had a
crush on this lady there was two girls
in my neighborhood named the carnelli
sisters we'll find her one was better
than the other one the old one was
engaged the kid that was basically my
brother right and the other one was just
a beautiful beautiful girl that dated a
couple guys in the name but I never had
any sexual encounters we grew up
together we were goombazz I really like
Kathy but a mother you know the Apple
don't fall far from the tree
right the mother was bang when I was 13
yes being a mother like was the hottest
thing on the planet to me I get Farrah
Fawcett yeah this fella for cheryl ladd
kind of looking yeah but this
[ __ ] was in front of me every
day she had real [ __ ] titties and
she'd wear a halter top oh yes and she
had a flat stomach with shorts and she
wear flip-flops and her feet was dirty
but she had two French poodles that were
blind right so she'd have to cross the
street with them and put lay him down on
the park right and we'd be playing
basket one and I throw the basketball
over just so much slide next to her
right so I could see her titties and
grin that age when he was going home
like I would see her tits and have to go
behind the tree and bang one out I was
if you're at that age when girls got a
jerk off because you can't take it no
more you got a bang one out outside no
inside in the mausoleum yeah I'm sorry I
mean that's how high she was leave when
you're 13 and you're a young man
13:14 you going through a bag of [ __ ]
emotions I came Catholic neighborhood
right so wasn't like girls would give it
up [ __ ] and I wasn't looking to get it
cuz I came from a Catholic made but all
right so you're walking around but
you're you're inside they're telling you
something different something good ones
you wanna [ __ ] and suck and you know but
you don't know about coming to Maui I
can come in people's eyeballs you just
want to crack a nut and get 13 you know
so I mean I she was the prettiest thing
I had ever seen him on she single no
she's avoiding this divorced look mister
cardinality push now she had if she was
37 36 her husband was about 55 well he
had Dori me so but he knew how fine she
was right so he would sit on the balcony
and watch her while she would walk the
dogs right and if you got too close to
he's like get the [ __ ] away from my wife
because that's how [ __ ] fine she was
so freaky for a year I kept I mean I
know since I was 10 no I developed her
hair but she was just bangin and there
was no faith takes back there was 1975
so yeah this happened this incident
happened send me not she had big [ __ ]
juicy titties right but I also know this
son knows that whenever I was playing
basketball at night when she would walk
the dog a husband would come on the
balcony so this would be my chance to
get her along really all right so I
thought I would talk to I would go to
the basketball courts just a watcher
come out like at 10:30 right and then I
talked to hi Thomas Connelly and we
talked a little bit and I check around
that night she was even so much you just
walk bikini top yeah great like she just
had a great body guys so I'm going
through all this [ __ ] at home puberty
bagging jerking off and after about six
months I said that's it I got had enough
I'm [ __ ] say like I'm just I'm
[ __ ] say I'm gonna do it I ain't
[ __ ] say I mean I was in love with it
so what I went out with those guys in my
house my mother was at home we got
[ __ ] up we listen to both sides of Led
Zeppelin too we were fired up
and they went to a party and I went and
hidden phase bushes
I thought she came down the stairs and I
had like little flowers she's not hiring
I sweat on my mother's grave well what I
like the you want the [ __ ] truth out
they the truth dick Taylor you're a kid
you don't [ __ ] know
flowers you don't [ __ ] know that's
why I think it's unfair
listen if a producer that's fifty and he
you're forty on the set but if you're
gonna come at me for something I did in
college or high school learning your
masculinity right if you didn't stick it
up your ass and beat you to death I
don't want to hear me insane if he
grabbed your teddy or took it he is that
kind of funny when you're 18 man doesn't
even know his masculinity they don't
even you know hold it you get these
feelings you know I think about it now
because I wrote a joke about it one
night I was thinking about you know how
hard it was for me at that age like the
hard-ons and the [ __ ] and the wanting
to have sex but you can't because you're
Catholic you know and the hell we like
all that you know have a rekt you are
you forgiving no hole direct who the
[ __ ] knows that mean I'm just saying
that you just feel like you're in the
middle of this thing you don't know
whether you could [ __ ] us up to be evil
and then one day you go [ __ ] it I just
don't you know sucking Teddy's and
struggling by Lincoln ration and then
when I will go to confession on Sundays
and Saturdays at 5:00 but you have to
tell them yourself you'd have to say
like I yeah like I suck some girls
titties uh-huh
yeah the Lord says you cannot fornicate
that you marry you want to [ __ ] the
ruling one go give me five our fathers
have to see you suck at it four five all
five hundred [ __ ]
I'll keep sucking kitten finger-banging
bitching they just forget to mention it
because what are you gonna talk about it
for oh my god so you know I was going
through this thing and I was in love
with Fang so I got flowers like a
bouquet like dandelions like some
[ __ ] bouquet I just hid in the weeds
and I saw her come out with her hot
pants and the flip-flops and a little
hole at the top and I didn't know
whether to tackle thinking about the
flowers the dogs are blind right on the
bark they're just gonna be walking
around what's going on
Elam saying ain't got like worldwide
sticks so as I foots creepin up on that
she turned around and she goes Coco what
are you doing out and I go Fay
listen I'm in love with you and I just
blew her mind like she knew me as a
little kid he's like what do you know
about flowers and off I go free just
want to run away with you you said that
really yeah I said those exact stupid
work you know right that's good one to
look so we don't gonna good line we
never like I never forget when I say it
good when I say a good joke I forget it
yeah it's when you say something stupid
to somebody that it reminds you for the
rest of your life I guess it'd make my
hope they don't remember in 83
yeah are you run away with me right you
run away with me and she's like what are
you talking about
like I just I don't wanna run away with
you we'll go somewhere and I'll get a
job I'm like I be with you he's like hey
you [ __ ] you didn't say that she knew I
was young and she's like well that's
very sweet of you
she goes what I'll do is this if he if
me and my husband have had a problem
kind of surprising and murder the poor
guy you know and I just stood there like
beet red they took my flowers and I
don't say I really love you yeah then
she got that she got I could tell I
scared just we had that Harvey
Weinstein's face to us he's a little
scared
you know I'm 13 I can't I said can I
kiss you
you should go J kiss me on the cheek and
I kissed her on the cheek yeah and then
I sat there for like three more minutes
to stare that down she said are you okay
I want your clothes or what your tits
tonight after she let me kiss her my
dick was hard my face was red you know
my blood was I'll tell her yeah
Thirteen's rambling I was 510 okay and I
[ __ ] said can I touch your leg like
that's my me to story yeah and I bent
over and I touched like right above her
kneecap without her saying yes she said
yes she said yes she said yes if you
like they could let you go
I deal with it I think if this if
touching my leg makes you get the [ __ ]
out of here I'll go ahead like that's
like above her kneecap
right I felt boy every sperm I had come
out of my pants
and I just ran all mine like [ __ ]
like Steve's a guy like you doll I ran
the [ __ ] calm and I just [ __ ] here we
go good or like three days later I'm
like I'm sorry and she's like how it
happens all the time then but about two
years ago I'm at lunch with her
son-in-law okay oh how the [ __ ] is fade
though can he go she's still 80 and
she's still alive she was she lives with
us and I haven't paid the story I almost
raped - one night nobody thought that I
called the Himalaya laughing he's like I
gotta tell you so you know how's she
looking these days yeah I think oh she
don't look [ __ ] bad for 80
she still has great tits she stars a
great ankle dub but he goes she's horny
as [ __ ] I go how do you know she's
always talking about it dinner yeah so
one man I'm sick after I forget about it
but a month man it's going and it's
Bobby I go what's up Bobby because it's
not somebody wants to talk to you and
they put her on the phone and she's like
why you when I need you now I'm Olly and
I'm like I like how you doing things and
I think you can tell him Bobby that
story I had forgotten about of this [ __ ]
huh yeah yeah how'd you tag that man
just jump in there pull those diapers
there I didn't I didn't [ __ ] y'all off
she's 80 who the [ __ ] knows what's going
on with you that much man just you look
good
thanks man that you're working on your
build yeah we're gonna do a few pull-ups
and then I you know how's the program
working program is working okay you know
I see here I hit the meetings once in a
while but managed it just going through
the meetings of you know you just got to
get the right one because I'm just sick
and tired of high it's my birthday you
know those those kind of meetings and
then uh the ones I'm going to are just
pretty good I mean they got the your
regulars and stuff like that but you
clean your drinking uh I'm clean but nap
drink I'm drinking water but you keep it
away from the evil you I can walk
through where I date pretty well you
know and just walk right past the liquor
but what is what do they have yellow
caps you know he's thinking what
would they put yellow caps on the vodka
what you're just pondering so yeah like
how long you've been cleaned from the
bottle for sure I would say more than
I'd say over a year and how do you feel
about it well I feel I can get up little
more you know I get up early in the
morning now I noticed that this morning
you thought you got me back at 8:35 8:35
but then I go back and take a little nap
you get a little cereal hit take a nap
and then uh and then I just get a
hard-on down so I think the vitamins and
stuff like that that you sent me the
garlic take the garlic yeah three of
those how good of the farts oh yeah the
most dear gasps oh my god I father and
the others book bastard
right and it's something for those was
that I have you to thank for the garlic
tabs the garlic - yeah but the odorless
but no they're not and they really work
Oh after you fill him sent me that and
the powdered that you sent me great
thank you for the water hey Fox and you
know the case of the water I got a case
of water I will send your water Pablo
that's the guy that this the type of guy
this [ __ ] is you know but the I
read up on the garlic and I gotta tell
you something you helped the results you
can feel it after about three weeks
later though right I felt the results at
kickboxing what I have to do anything
cardio right I feel that it I always
have
I'm old and I smoke pot in my lungs are
in bad shape right I always have a fear
the first 15 minutes okay after you do
cardio what I'm well kickboxing okay
like if I'm doing the myths or something
great the first three or four rounds I
have a weird feeling to me right and
then the next three or four rounds once
I get to the six or seven I loosen up
right since I started the pills I think
I'm getting more blood flow yeah because
I have more endurance in the seventh and
eighth and ninth round right I'm kicking
and punching harder right so I can feel
that I'm just not doing it for form I'm
actually feel any different you feel
here okay and then I watch that
documentary the other day GameChanger
yeah yeah I've been really thinking you
watching me yeah
what did you think um it makes sense it
makes sense so the whole thing is that
that plant-based diet really helps with
your blood pressure and all the stuff in
the meat it uh it's it's it's very
frustrating as someone who struggles
with weight how they were saying like Oh
doctors you just just say have chicken
and fish and and even that's not really
good for you so it's like it's uh it's
amazing how how little we know and how
he'll like it can have that big of a
difference like the blood pressure that
they show her how it went down and all
that it's it was interesting how they
were saying oh well we think were meat
eaters but maybe they had the occasional
meat but it's most of the time I was
probably just veggies and it's uh I
don't know it's I like it's kind of
weird it got me to think they didn't
really talk about this but we're like
the only Pew like animals to eat for
pleasure everyone else to see if you see
a dog they just eat what they're eating
it doesn't really matter
and we're like meat tastes good but that
obviously they had some negative things
for you I no meat for me at my age at
night I feel it
do I feel it the next day no I don't I
don't know what the [ __ ] do you plant
stomachs for I feel sugar the next day I
had dessert the airline for the first
day of war four ways we shared spoons
and I had dessert
and I felt the sugar the next day in
fact I felt the sugar than having a
workout just to sweat it out a little
bit yeah you think along sides that it
feels really good it's weird that you
haven't transferred just because the
whole thing about really ending of an
addiction is transferring that addiction
yeah you can take it and put some trans
place yeah uh you know for me it was
going back to working out you know like
I like and I enjoy it it keeps my powder
dry right I'm gonna keeps my powder
driver it's a half hour I would half a
class leave it in the bag after why just
something that I could put the phone
away but right thanks that
we're essentially escaping right when
we're doing a 12-hour [ __ ] run right
on site yet so now I do little escapes
what's an escape not having any
responsibility for an hour right and
that's you leave your phone in the car I
know my wife is home if something
happens at the school or something
pick it up right that's peace of mind
absolutely that willpower means so much
in your life
you know and you're a young comic your
mind is obsessed right what's succeeding
and the engineering your agents and then
one day you trying to be 40 in year 15
20 years and you see as long as you stay
active and stay true and keep writing
right you always want to have a job yeah
you know you're always gonna have work
and you get some years yeah
becoming Kevin Hart is a lottery ticket
yeah you know becoming successful just
being successful and happy land is what
you're striving for here I'm saying
during the app I'm like I've told you in
the beginning you know I got a lot of
emails from people who are struggling
with addiction where you know when they
listen to the show and they feel better
it overcomes them if anybody had an
addiction he couldn't shake for a long
time beside me it's you oh yeah man it
was fun it was it's all about having fun
man for me I'd moved my daddy he's all
clothes here it was all about having fun
with me I mean thing was I didn't have
no problems with my childhood you know
my daddy touched me my ass or anything
like that I just was basically having a
good time and it just rolled amber and
my friends were you when you started
drinking I started drinking uh 15 years
old heart pounding was the first time
you don't wanna coke
I didn't line of coke at my history
teachers house he used to used to be a
free enterprise in history at our high
school and he ended up living down the
street from us and we just had party
with him and I did Metallica's master of
puppets' came out and I was like took my
first line I was like lips got numb
teacher was there it was all good how
old were you I was 16 [ __ ] yeah dude rat
came out and it was just the best mom
the crews just doing lines and just
little potting lines all the time I
could take it to I was good I had a good
you know metabolism back there but after
a while man well God going in this class
stone and my god thinking you're gonna
get bused in yours like this is looking
around like that and your friends are
looking dude your ice rattling oh God
and I thought was gonna get busted in
English class first first period and I
was just like my blazing I was gone my
god I got so stone and everyone's
looking at me go man are you stoned man
if you look high and then the teacher
comes he goes you know what it's gonna
be a movie today and the lights go down
I went oh saved saved by the whole thing
so that's how I mean never get high in
in high school right only like what that
one time but on the weekends I just go
but for this what's the longest you've
been clean before this uh it's two years
there was no one major relapse that time
uh found it my house you know in between
some books and just came out and just
had the day off and then you know year
and a half why not do a little bit
maintain it you know I just did two days
with it and drink oops oh my god tons of
beer and then just went back to sober
again but uh you know just just doing a
bomb right now whoo I'm like wrong
I kind of use I'll try forget
cottonmouth with that kind of stuff you
know so we and I'm about two weeks away
from not doing coke for 12 years no way
really totally so I wow you count that
high he's you good lord man get rid of
it when I was the old me you know I
think they told a story on re and red
bands podcast right about me slamming
the computer on red bands finger and I
called Brian yeah dad I know how all of
you know this part that was my third
month to sobriety well when I was
January of 2008 and we were at Cobbs
comedy club you know I got clean like
November 10th there's something like
that of 2007 what's his blow just blow
right just blow how cool you know I was
I wasn't really a drinker
right my thing was that cocaine by
myself how would you come down just just
smoke weed let smoke weed ID uh maybe a
pill okay whatever you had you know but
the pills would take me somewhere else
it's funny I watched all of my last
night okay okay and he says a line in
the beginning of that there at the diner
and he gets upset and he goes to his car
and he goes you know I've been here all
this time and nothing has happened in my
life and he goes whatever I'm selling
and all these body right and the way he
said it and the way he meant it as a
comic you get to that point right yeah
well you like whatever I'm selling they
don't want to buy it whether it's a
script right my act you know I'm just
[ __ ] death you know and right
he becomes you know for me that was uh
what made me quit like I was like I
either have to [ __ ] do this on
they're not buying what I'm selling no
more right like yeah lockdown picked up
some movies a show like that but I'm not
gonna pick them on anymore because the
words gonna get out right real words
gonna gather this is a big problem I had
already had problems I said along the
shore and I had problems in the cellar
saw the movie I quit this job over you
know and I could lie to everybody and
say that yeah I had another job like
doing Mountain Dew but I can't sold that
[ __ ] movie that time the people came
to my house and I pushed the producer
well cocaine-induced Wow
you know that was all cocaine-induced
you know man you're selling coke til six
you gonna come banging on my door at
9:00 oh no I'll stab me in the wall and
then when I tell you to go away you keep
banging on my door I got a banging
headache I feel bad enough
Big D was already called me twice
because I didn't put the $50 in this
saddle and took the coke right yeah no I
need you knock about my daughter go to a
[ __ ] movie down the corner about the
dumbest thing I've ever heard about my
life you know I think the words gonna
get out yeah I wouldn't you know words
gonna get out
I didn't want it to get out and if it
did get out I wanted to correct it with
those people you know like after I got
cleaned I would let her have him like a
year later all right and he put me in a
movie you know I can write at him a
letter and mix along with him well it
was movies it's cool man I still Howard
you either or whatever right
you know but I'm at that whole incident
in Cobbs happened because I was still
running a little shaky nine or dazing
[ __ ] right right ninety days this thing
could turn and I know now from talking
to other people who have done what we've
gone through that it could change any
day so I have to check myself every day
right
i I've had around I know people have had
in their pocket yeah I know it's at
certain places that I frequent but it
doesn't affect me I can't think of going
back to that life oh yeah it's uh I
can't think of all I think I would die
of a heart attack yeah
right off the bat my goodness age with
what I've done and how hard I've done to
repair everything the garlic pills the
cardio right I think that like this
podcast would not still be intact if I
was doing well they love inhale away go
a lot quicker fight it's like no no no
nobody would show this poor kid would
still be at two years ago sitting here
waiting for them who shows that month
when you're on coke it's a 50/50 it is a
50/50 chance usually fill up you're not
gonna do the lesser you do any plans
with me it's 50/50 yeah and like so I
know you now or at least I feel like I
know you pretty well and like you're
you're punctual you get mad like you
know when other people you're very on
your calendar like what do you what do
you feel bad about it and the time
beaters like I can't leave the house
right now I'm too [ __ ] up or it's just
yeah changes it to the point where you
think you could you can probably mention
to your way out of it now get out of the
situation you can probably blame it on
traffic but I I said stupid had stoop
excuses every man my arm fell off kind
of thing and I really believed it so but
you know
get sick all the time it says though you
know I just remember you know there's a
time where I could not sleep stop doing
coke at 4:00 and get in a car at 6:15
and go on a plane ride feel a little
creepy at the airport but as time went
on the addiction turned into something
different and they got to the point that
if I was high till 4:00
I wouldn't even leave the house it sinks
like I would call the comedy clubs and
Sam I'm getting on the plane I'm headed
to the airport but I wasn't even leaving
the [ __ ] house I did it to about four
or five comedy clubs you know I think I
did it to Joe one time you know I mean
and you see how I am about comedy no no
you know like I can't see that it wasn't
me it was whatever I was doing that was
I mean the last year I canceled a gig so
let's say you were supposed to leave
Friday Thursday night or Thursday night
on the day like okay I'm not gonna get
high tonight I'm not gonna get high and
then at the last hacking like [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me go get a package I'll be
fine all depends how good the show is
you know if you could if you rock you
want to Brie up no no but I'm talking
about even getting that Oh get down
there I wouldn't even make it to the
plane like I would leave and I'll have
the owner of the club waiting for me at
the airport calling me going where I
don't know my plane got delayed we got
the bunk Oklahoma and now the channel
ganado and they're still gonna go we'll
come in tonight we'll replace you
tonight coming for tomorrow and I would
still make up a story like it was that
bad and I think of my life now you know
you made it if you made plans with me to
see me at 1:00 in the afternoon it was
all 5050 even more even on the day yeah
I didn't do it in the daytime but when
you wake up at 8:00 and you have the
depression from the night before
or you go to bed at 8:00 in the morning
I go to bed at 8:00 you know I would I
would the last year I would stay up and
folk Terri would wake up to go to work
and in the last half hour she would dad
was just faking that would sleep with my
eyes closed
meanwhile my heart pounding in the
[ __ ] bed and she's getting ready
around me as soon as she would leave I
was like I was like a brat the [ __ ]
relief yeah I can open my eyes and jerk
off one more time try to fall back to
sleep I don't I don't I don't read those
things
I don't dread [ __ ] over Peter because
that's the only part but towards the end
you're [ __ ] yourself over but more or
less you're [ __ ] people oh man I mean
and it just this isn't just myself you
know I heard he'll tell you I think
he'll do tell you the last year the last
day of crashing he just didn't show you
know rest in peace I love him with all
my heart I mean it's well documented and
this is where our [ __ ] world falls
apart and again the Feeny would
disappear for three days come back and
pay for the production I know a friend
he did it to his movie and he gave one
to twenty thousand for the day of
production and I know for a fact he did
a movie in New Orleans and he went out
and supposedly somebody slipped them
illness at the strip club they couldn't
get ahold him he had a pain for the
whole day of production unless Sean Penn
movie 250,000 you know that's your
nature to disappear I would disappear
for three days leave where you couldn't
and there was no cell phones no in the
80s you just call the house right
disappear is there a way to describe it
to someone like I'm trying to like me I
the only I can't even I can't even wrap
my head around it who wasn't attractive
let's just say Kate Quigley okay quickly
okay
Friday you go out you get your paycheck
for 800 for two weeks
and you go on spend 500 on conquer bag
because Joey's supposed to buy you split
it with you but I got [ __ ] up a night
before I spent the money from that coke
so now you're stuck with the whole seven
grams and you go to the Communist donut
hole you bump at the cake quickly she's
kind of dress on you could tell she's
got a thong on you got two lines in you
so cake Quigley's looking completely
different than what she looks like to
you now great cake was not your friend
yeah when you look at her on cocaine she
was like a victim like she's just an ass
she's just uh well uh what the cheaters
go after those kids I'll pray yeah yeah
that's what she is
she's just pray so now let's pretend you
went to Pablo hmm you should Pablo give
me that seven grams on the arm I'm gonna
sell to Jodi is I'm gonna get properly
so now even though you got it in your
pocket and you're gonna make a profit on
Jodi is and you still are Pablo five
hundred you don't look at Kane I'm just
using kids right Apple cuz everybody
knows that she's a pretty girl I could
use a thousand other girls but she
coming with whatever you know they got a
thong on they bent over these over do
coke you give them a package you make
them go to the bathroom they do two
bumps they come back they take the coke
is great and then they come back give
you two more now it's drain them one now
what we're gonna go I live in Studio
City I got another seven grams up there
can't quickly or whoever it is gonna
come up there with it yep now the first
gram that you do you're okay because
you're in profit okay alright he just
losing a little profit
you still got Pablo's money tomorrow but
next thing then are you talking to
taking the top off and you want to do
two bumps off your tits
she's smart pretty soon [ __ ] [ __ ]
Joey's Pablo now we'll move without the
[ __ ] Pablo's money
even though you and Pablo best friend
did you grow up the Pablo that addiction
makes you tell Pablo go [ __ ] himself
even though in real life you would never
tell pop I was your best friend and Jo
is your best
but you're just selling your soul right
now for Kate a [ __ ] and that cocaine
now you know how long that lasted do all
that coke Friday from 3:00 in the
morning to Saturday night at 6:00 of the
night yeah so you guys pretty basically
staying all afternoon maybe go for a
walk to get beer right and go right back
to do that coat every 20 minutes and
because [ __ ] [ __ ] suck whatever you got
now Sunday morning Kate you wake up at
2:00 in the afternoon Cain's gone you
look at your phone you got six missed
messages
Pablo Joey hasn't called Joey called
last night because he got money a night
before mm-hmm
so it's you give up so much for this
addiction like you so put a lot of
effort and nothing it's a lot of effort
into nothing and [ __ ] your friends
now you gotta go face Pablo and make up
a lot of Pablo that the cops pulled over
and took it [ __ ] took intersession
you've got no money and you'll pay him
$50 a week for 18 weeks well you talked
to me or told stories about times when
like you know at when you didn't even
want the girls to come over so it's just
you by yourself it was out there was a
point where I did because the addiction
keeps growing that's what people don't
understand
Pablo's cleaning him but inside of him
that addiction has grown oh yeah if he
can that's why so many whoa I'm lying to
you like when people go back to heroin
they shoot the amount they were shooting
before they went to rehab and they get a
heart attack
they OD because it was there I was the
tolerance one loving play your desire
for kuzco he was growing so when you're
an addict does as they describe an
addict you know I hear a lot of words
when people describe I can't describe
adequately describe the Z's in my world
I was an addict okay how was it I would
wake up at 8:00 in the morning first
thing I thought about was coke the
second thing was calming hmm and how was
I gonna get the money for the coke to do
the Kali
King Kong King company and that's that's
an attic that's an addict and guess what
I have the rent money but the rest not
due till the fifth so even though it's
twenty nine I got the rent money I'm
good till Monday [ __ ] all bets are off
and guess what it's Halloween Thursday
I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna stay clean
following but I'm buying an eight ball
ten quaaludes just to start the party
off and that's how you think that how
you think so I know I was sensitive at
the 90-day mark I'm trying to think back
to because after you know I spoke to
Burt two days ago and I said how's it
going and he knows I feel good and he
said something that made me very happy
goes I think I'm gonna give this a shot
and really want to give this a shot I'm
feeling that much better you know do you
feel the change absolutely where do you
see changes I start enjoying uh going
out and seeing you know I like taking
long walks now you know check out the
neighborhood I've been getting into more
of the animals out there I know it
sounds crazy but that's I'm recognizing
a lot of things that I missed when I was
growing up you know just the reaction of
people and how these talk to each other
sometimes sometimes I would just stay in
my room
you just watch TV and get on the
internet but I feel I feel more strength
you know I feel what more it definitely
builds up your confidence but uh it's uh
you go back and you see your friend
still doing it you know and they're
they're older than you and and they
still you know pull out a bump inside it
kind of trips me out but uh man I go if
you guys still you still keep it in a
file you know you still do that little
bump anything yeah man but they just
hope they continue they stay in one spot
but they get more they get more aware
about how it had some good times on it
had some bad times on it right and they
still have a fight about how they
screwed up and they always say it's not
coke or pod but that fell to change in a
more responsible you know I can and
smoke a lot of cigarettes though that's
not too
but other than that man I feel I feel
that I'm having my shields go by quicker
you know I don't have to steal like I'm
struggling through him you know you're
bringing a soul before nobody on the
road yeah it's easy yeah I bring up very
diamond you know very diamond goes with
me on the road do you really yeah he's
great he's fantastic man we're playing
Ontario this week but uh are you sober
oh yeah he's totally sober man how old
is Barry oh I know you don't what I
don't know how old he is but good guy no
good funny dude good God hilarious the
first time I saw him was in that movie
with Tom Hanks oh yeah that's the part
of the party and I fell in love with him
I know he was a wild man and might you
see him up at the store and so the wild
wild west yeah he's got he's still a
wild man but you know for me I think the
first two years I was on eggshells until
I could actually believe that I was
clean
like actually bullying like this is not
right I am you know more than $18 in my
ATM account I get up early in the
morning you said the word confidence I
started counting on myself right yeah
yeah so the more I can count on myself
the better I could make myself like I
figured out everybody in LA you got a
meeting with somebody at Jerry's diner
when you're 15 minutes late
everybody else is 20 minutes late and
people like oh sorry the traffic well
[ __ ] you grew up in LA right you should
know that he grew up and my
responsibility is to be there you know
so I started getting sharper in those
things
right yeah I grew balls back I wasn't an
addict anymore
right so when you told me to go [ __ ]
myself now my first reaction used to be
go for an hour go you know what I'm
gonna end up in jail and then I can't
snort you so let me just walk away from
this situation weed makes me which
didn't make me look bad it made me feel
bad feeling I should have choked those
[ __ ] guys the saying that then you
know I realized that I wasn't an addict
no more that was a man again you want to
make a statement to people I didn't
become a man so I was 44 when I made the
decision to get two out of my life I
that was when I became a man I didn't
know what to like 47 yeah all these
little things you know what made me
better you know and I want the same for
you Leon that's why I want you to come
on the podcast every six weeks and
report
yeah man does this will give you
something even if you relapse
we don't even [ __ ] man he goes you know
I tried to quit from I think I started
quitting in 2004 right you know for
anybody who knows anything about
quitting drugs or whatever Hey Dude go
cold turkey god bless you
well I started quitting like in 2004 my
by 2007 I was on heroin really working
my system isn't working so I have to
figure out another system why I knew
rehab was not the answer right I knew it
that level rehab was not the answer very
expensive I knew that uh people are gone
in and out of rehabs and I figured out
something one day that was just amazing
I go you know what when you watch Carly
those white Mike he says that he had a
counselor imprison that Tom that you
know you could run and run and run but
one day he thought left you just can't
run them right and you know the life I
was living it was running every day I
was hustling a package really you know
some coke trying to make this you know
it's stressful running it's stressful
that's too much stress oh yeah I got to
think about too much to put on too much
ain't gonna be there ready will not be
there will I make my set right you know
you call the guys and meet your 7-eleven
and Magnolia at 8:30 got a 9:15 in
[ __ ] Oxnard
you know you can really make yourself
allow that yeah you're gonna meet him at
8:30 and make it to Oxnard in 10 minutes
like [ __ ] like that and I'll simulate
I'll never forget doing something
towards the end that was the Improv got
really pissed at me right like The
Improv had heard bits and pieces of what
I was doing but one night that gave me a
chance after
get the guy's name Fred and okay what's
it thing Oxnard
this is Ontario okay
he was one of the oldest or something of
marketing the senior VP okay he was an
older guy hanging around him promise I
don't think he liked me you know as it
was and I had gotten the longest yard
and they were trying to the the you know
I spoke to partner one day and right you
know he said okay we'll start giving you
break off nights whatever he came
through Hartman came through and they
gave me Wednesday and Thursday well at
the Ontario improv and all I had to do
was Wednesday Thursday and do radio
Thursday morning right know I'm lying to
you how to do they want me to go into
Ontario they got me a hotel yeah I'll
get you hotel on a Tuesday right and
they wanted me to get up for radio
Wednesday and Thursday right you did you
like to get to peaceful Wednesday yeah
usually it's yet both you and I drove
from Hollywood Ontario check then went
to my room set up to sleep at me machine
the whole thing laid down both ready to
go to sleep I said I need a bump and I
got back in my car drove the hour 10 the
Hollywood great got a package and drove
the hour 10 back to Ontario
I stayed up till 8:00 I didn't get back
to Ontario till midnight 12:30 you know
how to stop me and those days I stopped
and get one beer
Oh God just one beer to kill the initial
bump the beginning warm water after that
right and I you know the radio guys were
outside call and I'm not answering the
hotel's banging on the door I got the
lock they can't open yeah I think I just
some sick I got the flu but they know
what time it was and the atom like 24
people there on Wednesday 12 on Thursday
and I got a call like a week later like
lose on them right thing the [ __ ]
improv it's Fool's Day no but like you
know like this type of [ __ ] and this is
like February of 2000 yeah okay next
twenty years ago I was worried I
couldn't open throw gonna TM prize but
then right now I'm not you still show
your Paul's you know no no no at that
time they were like they were like you
know it's so funny how you do something
a couple of times and people go crazy
over it
I stopped showing my balls like 2002
right once I got MADtv unhappy show me
let's go to the clip then I showed my
balls and Brea I would take I would open
up my zipper and just let my balls hang
up come believe it yeah people would go
nuts
some people would walk they go for a
minute and then they would just go like
what does that mean milk no how would
just let the 2 balls up can you imagine
what happened we did that now this is
just to show you how crazy I was there
was a video of me that wrote the
Christmas choir made of me jumping to
Rogen's poster and I was naked and I
would dance and they shot in Brea and
the old brand-new a movie the movie
theater yeah oh my god I got a call that
Tuesday from the info like are you
[ __ ] nuts
you shot it right under the improv sign
like I was just you know it was like one
disaster after another right those that
is the scrap the result of an addiction
it's that your life is a [ __ ] zig zag
so no you get flat tires
yeah you just you know you get it done
the curse of bad planes planes change in
the last minute you know it's not your
fault but then sometimes you you have to
change them yourself and they don't
believe you need yeah no no and then
everything that could happen is gonna
happen right so on top of what I'm
creating in my life life is not throwing
curveballs down my [ __ ] throat yeah
you know you plan on is this what you
want to do yeah that mos def aluminum I
want to get into yeah
come - right now I'm just saving my
Halloween you know I'm 50 years old you
know Pablo when I saw that documentary
for Ray Charles yeah it said that he got
sober at the age of 60 my heart stopped
I come like I can't do this no no no way
man yeah I think I don't know what the
age was somebody check it for me
or whatever what you know at the end it
said that he did heroin to the age of 60
something Wow you know that pet
petrified me like I just had a lot of
signs the right of that telling me to
stop the race you know
yeah religion gets involved too and it's
thinking about you know your life and
you know all you get and you're gonna
keep over you can still be doing this
and you know you see your friends do I
see my friends do it and I've you know
up with drink and you know it's like a
minute back to same you know going back
to that same lifestyle sometimes and I
just go that's the next topic we gotta
cover the next topic I had to change and
I was just talking to somebody last
night about this my brother was on the
phone me and he asked me some questions
about some [ __ ] about a particular
person the summit I don't know I haven't
spoken to that person is and he asked me
why not and I said because my
relationship with that person was
strictly cocaine right and funny
anything else no I wasn't behind him it
wasn't a dealer it was a chemically I
grown up with door somebody I had known
to Frenchmen and I said to him you know
it's weird and I hate to say this on the
podcast but someday you'll have to do it
when it's a you know you you know they
say you have growth spurts when you're a
kid yeah okay like Dennis Rodman had
like a 7-inch growth spurt when he was
19 years old
really yeah it's the weirdest things we
have growth spurts okay okay then
quad that growth is looking around you
know and in 2007 I actually have a look
around when I got off the coke and see
who was working right
whirring what was working and what
wasn't working it's a tough decision to
me right especially you're a person like
me that cares about his friends right
but you also have to care about your
future this is what I want to do right
so these are the don't worry about my in
66 he got clean at 66 no in 66
understanding how all he was well that
he died like within 80 Ray Charles oh
yeah you got clean at 66 years I think
something like that was 54 don't worry
buds okay just to prove I just didn't
want to be that but I knew that if at 64
if I was still doing coke right I saw a
Joe Diaz with no hair no teeth you know
I saw Joe Diaz that was 400 pounds I
knew nothing would get better right so I
died that's when I started thinking
about being getting sober trying right
you know I have a [ __ ] and I live a
couple lives like I have a couple
friends now that are hitting our age
right and they're still drinking like
you know yeah 1988 and they have no
successes in their life I could tell
they're not happy some of them we just
fell by the wayside right things what
happened is now also is that people like
a man I was tight with you for years
doing Tommy and now I'm not even in your
[ __ ] world right and your radar
anymore I'm still like an open mic er so
I lost them because we just don't really
you know you lose them but there was two
things for me to get clean right and
there was a point with comedy I said I
gotta take all these people out of the
rolodex great they just they just bring
me down like the name but I wouldn't
because there was like three agents in
particular my three people who had all
the potential to help me here I was
friends with them I wasn't kissing their
ass I would work hard for them or
whatever and we won't get nowhere and
one day I said you know what not only am
I not gonna work
I'm cutting the markers in a kiss of
debt they got this guy on the roster or
this guy in the roster you know I don't
want to be the same roster as screech
yeah you know so he got Jodi is Pablo in
screech oh yeah I'll call you back
tomorrow yeah I just know connects for
me they make these leaps in life
you have to leave some luggage behind
right and sometimes luggage is people
sometimes you can't take them happy man
you can't take them with you even though
you love them whatever you party but
it's the only thing you have in common
that's it that's it that's it then went
overseas no Kiseki big right I'm doing
nothing right yeah I'm getting a college
for this and that's another rest of the
time and I lost you know 20 20 of those
people oh yeah okay and people that I
actually loved but I still think about
the lay a night I know they're still
doing it it's not like kids I grew up
with nothing like that it's people that
I've met along the journey that every
time I would go to Pittsburgh they would
show up on an eight ball every time I
would show up to Nashville they would
show up with an A for every time I
showed up to Atlanta they would show up
on a table every time I showed up move
into Miami they brought oh yeah after
ship you know there were certain people
in every market but I had that again it
was rough to say them know I'm coming in
and I'm going out and they're like what
am I gonna see and not really but don't
you want a point I got this chick that
lets me [ __ ] her in front of people I
really know you know I had all that
creepiness yeah I had career sweetness
you know it's not even peer pressure
it's like it's just it don't mean they
expect you know hey listen I'm going
back to the hotel they can't even take
that it's no no I had this success of
the only success I had was in finding
cocaine I was like a successful treasure
hunt that is the only success I ever had
there was a period there were I would
bump into cocaine even if I didn't want
if he was like a curse Wow like you
really wanted we're gonna give him these
terribly I met at coke I go to an
airport get a flight delay and the guy
next to me would say you want a bump
tell me you don't have a bump not only
do I have a bump
I gotta have found sound it would delay
for nine hours
you know I got a thousand of those
stories getting delayed in Aspen in
Denver and having to put your coke in
the locker what we can put taking like a
grandma at a time you know what I'm
gonna go to the barn or cousin those
days the inputs didn't close yeah the
bars were open 24 hours in an airport
till 5:00 they were closed for one hour
it'll close for one out for the janitor
come and wipe down the bar and steam it
yeah another bartender were coming so
you would buy six beers and just sit
there until 6:00 a.m. and older that
downs a day those were the days eight
you gonna sleep on the flight you gotta
get sleep on the flight I mean it was
crazy it was a crazier world but uh so
like a year and how often are you
feeling the urge to be like [ __ ] it
let's get some more coke a year in
you're still skittish oh yeah yeah yeah
I get skittish but no big time man for
me it listen I'm gonna be honest with
you this is just everybody it works
differently do I believe in a 12-step no
man I [ __ ] do 100% right absolutely
whether its food whether it's gambling
whether it's you know why because you
get to be around people who have the
same problems and you want to have the
answers right to your questions one of
those persons in one of those meetings
it's gonna get something out of the
answer to your own questions I went to a
thousand those meetings I didn't want to
go to I mean if I tell you that
sometimes I was bored that's the truth
but I got pain and sometimes I took some
great info out there yeah first of all I
stopped feeling pity for myself because
even though I was homeless this
[ __ ] lost an eyeball you know he
did so much coke his [ __ ] nose
collapsed no I mean I'm a no when you go
there yeah you know you playing a Gazoo
right through his I mean one time when I
went through one of the first times I
went to wait watch right the girl said
to me she goes if you think these are
bad at Hollywood go to the control
groups they call him or something yeah
when I go join his day night it wasn't a
woman's group it was like a Weight
Watchers group [ __ ]
I went down there and I was the fattest
guy in the room and I felt good when I
left right because I heard people crying
and I could tell that these people go
home at night and heat it the whole bag
oh yeah like they're crying even though
they go home I don't know what we're
doing you know what you're [ __ ] doing
you're going home at night you mean the
whole box of [ __ ] doughnuts that's
what you don't you know and you you know
so going to a 12-step I think it's great
for anybody it wasn't gonna work for me
like I knew I wasn't gonna go to the
meeting that I knew that one damn and I
get up and go [ __ ] all you [ __ ]
in and then I just worked the 12 steps
without going to meetings I did the
evaluation I did step four right
I did all those things you know I gave
myself up to a high of God you know once
I started doing those things I started
doing those things in my life I took
those twelve steps and I worked them in
different aspects of my life again but
you can't apologize to everybody right
you can apologize to most people and
they'll take your apology and that takes
a ton of weight off you every time you
know yeah you know I called all those
club owners that are probably still
waiting for me at the end keep the club
open till 9:00 you tell them at the show
you took my weeks pay man you just crazy
I remember guys going so why you gotta
be here or not I would be playing with
them at this point yeah yeah my planes
coming in at 8:40 all right we'll push
the show back till 9:00 oh that's cancer
you can't be this dumb what's the guy's
not there at 4:00 cancelled right but
get go go go tomorrow that sorry people
will give you a 15 back we'll give you a
coupon off to come see Ralph Kerry play
the drums or whatever the [ __ ] it is how
long did it take you to earn that trust
back for some Louis clubs 50 basilica's
clubs aren't even around okay I mean
okay the other 50% it took a while it
took a while and took a while was
showing up with other people
sorry you're not gonna hire me anymore
as a personal day but if I see Pablo's
da now come down when bob was there I
will drink I'll do 20 minutes for Pablo
I'll get my Congo it took about two
years and then there the guy from death
Dan from the improv call me like in 2009
right and he said were you started
roaming and I go well they're mad at me
and he goes I'll take care of that and
the rest is history it was never a
problem there anymore
once I got off the coke it's crazy how
like something that's so just a night
can like [ __ ] up years of your life yeah
well yeah it's heavy stuff sometimes
those nights you know could be a manager
just starting and he's giving out
refunds you know something like that too
much and yeah it's just your word and
your promises you make to these guys
just about you know I'm gonna be right
there and you don't show up yeah it's
get some and we do a tough job
not again I'm not patting myself in the
back breaking my hand to Pat myself on
the back but we caught a place that's
called the road and the road is a great
place to do comedy and for musicians and
stuff but it also has a lot of pitfalls
yes enjoyable what pitfalls pitfalls are
you know me Pablo
Artie Lange once the word gets out that
you party people come to those shows
with the intention you can say anything
on the radio you can say get some
theorems you don't have it yeah yeah you
know I've had people say to me I bailed
her over 20 years and that one time have
I gotten cold talk about it on the radio
yeah I haven't done coke over four days
but I'm ready a rocking the idea
laughing giggling but there's some
[ __ ] that I was going I know
exactly what he's talking about
absolutely yeah I'm going now that it
brings from the [ __ ] to kill his wig and
nexi not you know and women a women show
up with coke with drugs or whatever you
know and I've had Road stories where
your Tunnel drop women who've shown up
with dates and have combination drugs do
you get crystal in there yeah they'll
say he's never bottomed out again Busta
Rhymes
drop drop this Hampton thing off and
come back and get here with coke and
it's you see addiction like I said here
think about it now you know I always
tell my book agent I want to but write a
couple books I got a couple books in it
because it took me and I think I react
has this that they look back at their
drug use and you like to write a book
yes I'm the steps of the detox you know
it's like when you quit smoking
cigarette as a guide somewhere
I think it's online the seven first days
what happened to through the 24 hours
you don't smoke Savior wait what happens
within 24 hours send me four hours a
week three months nine months twelve
years they tell you what happens to you
do you think you saved like I know I
know for a fact Pablo then when I was up
on when I got high the night before my
calmly on stage the next day would also
be 50/50 I felt yes connected yeah uh it
does take it away sometimes man if
that's it's kind of spooky week it's a
you tried to think about it and then
it's it would take it away just when I
would get on stage and then I get it
back but yeah I started finding out that
uh I couldn't you know state my couldn't
last too long man I'll be doing twenty
minutes you know what am I supposed to
do a half hour
whichever but you know it's just good
guy man and forgetting a lot of things
you know and you ever get high and going
straight well many times a night before
oh yeah I have I get good stats but you
know did I have a good set you know
sometimes I just go up there and just
tell the jokes real quick but I can jump
into topic the topic spinning around get
an idea write it down so I had other
friends that we're doing it too with me
you know on the road and you know he
would be like it'd be like we challenge
each other but then we drink and it was
just a game of just you know that it was
in a game it was just partying Jun shows
you know it's like it's incredible the
people you meet there they come right in
the green room these are partying these
come let him do it but like so you know
you're on stage during the first look
man I know they're doing bumps back
there you know at second show comes okay
when you bump with them and then
everything starts changing so how's your
life changing
jiya save money got money no but uh and
uh what else have you know just my
health is better you know I've got more
strength and you know the ideas come
with a little bit more clear but than
that man it's just I'm so smoking
cigarettes you know so just lots of
things listen we all can't be on a
percent perfect yeah but yeah cigarettes
remember listen
cigarettes don't make you cancel a gig
so we all rights don't make you get a
jet get a jet you know - yeah cigarettes
don't make you do a lot of things that
cocaine would you know the impulse that
you get from doing coke like right now
between you and I I still have three or
four qualities left from doing coke that
and I have none coke in 12 years
like after effects that sometimes I
laugh when I'm doing well you know I
said I have more control now I'm like my
body in my mind I see sometimes that you
have still after mmm really I do not
with your speech but with yeah yeah with
my speech my speech by myself you know
yeah that I was I was always like that
since I was third grade but it's I have
noticed that you know I still haven't
articulated some of my my language no it
takes time yeah I know that survives
with your speech and with your I have
the same thing the same little manic
yeah presence that you have everybody
noticed it yeah so you're making people
nervous I go bad I'm feeling good right
now I'm journalize but yes but ya know
it takes it takes it takes a while to
lose all those go absolutely listen man
I'm happy you're putting it together
that's what works man you know there's a
lot of people that listened to these
podcasts and they get different things
from them you know I think this is the
the one that hits home the hardest with
this podcast there's when people come on
here and share their struggles to let
people know that we put our pants on one
leg at a time I don't ever want this
podcast
well there's a to a podcast I feel like
I'm getting talked down to that's the
end of my part that's seeing though
that's podcast I've always wanted this
podcast to let people know that you know
it's like when Molly crew got clean all
right they went on the road with sober
coaches I rang the guys cooked meals so
you know that costs $5,000 yeah at the
time that cost her a thousand dollars a
day so for somebody who right now is in
Ohio is Eno kids doing Joey you're not
doing nothing good for me you're talking
about in fact I said here said called
David Rafael you know yes you know he'll
go everywhere with you and hold your
hand you know not even be is financially
strapped now absolutely do that I know a
coach from here right now that is in New
York with you know when he tells me
these situations
he's a sober coach a professional
six-figure oh [ __ ] yeah yeah gangster
granny
okay but him and I have hard tardes in
fact I know two guys one of them is a
comic but I don't really know him as
water have art art but the thing he
tells me the most of my sober coaching
is it's like anything else he gets a lot
of his biggest age group is 19 to 25
okay and it's rich parents
yeah rich parents that not that they've
given up on the child but the child has
put them through so much over the last
five or six we had car crashes you have
dad theft
whatever the faretta car you know and
shame that he got they just wanna a
breather and they have these sober
coaches you go to a meeting with every
day and then sometimes he drops a urine
on yeah yeah he drops the urine on yet
he cooks for you he trained to you I
mean this guy's gets big money yeah you
know he started here and now he's like
nationally known you know as well but
not everybody could afford that you know
oh yeah so you've been I don't know I'm
the Rihanna's four or five or five and
they never really seemed to work they
just slow you down a little bit
they just slow the process down and you
learn what to tell them to get yourself
out oh yeah it's our daddy for turning
that barely afford yes really afford and
you know you learn what the time to get
out of there but you and I both know
that you you're gonna have Chico pick
you up and he's taking it the first bite
you're going doing it may not be the
first spot maybe we'll get some tacos
first to get the proper nourishment but
the second spot you're going to mr.
[ __ ] my man's house to pick up a
package how do I know because I've done
it I you know well that was in the
halfway house I would have to go see a
drug counselor I both local possessed
from an hour right and I'm still going
right from there the drug dealers house
of Dawkins
this mother you're celebrating said he
went to them yeah this guy didn't work
today you know I want the acupuncture to
deal with cocaine issues I told her the
truth in the beginning really and every
week a little needle in you yeah
so Jo said she'd stick a needle in me
you had that you would you would take it
to go do it's a needle that would stick
staying you for three days
what closing your nerve your cocaine
know when you're here lobe it's like a
staple and she would leave it in there
that it would fall out after three days
we just clicked and I still remember
snorting coke and be playing with him
like going lord please take this feeling
away and I would do a line of coke and
[ __ ] the hold on to my ear and but
room is serving away I learned about
acupuncture because if I was you Pablo I
go to acupuncture I thought you want
because acupuncture helps you build up
your Chi and if it helps your little
[ __ ] chakra zones and it builds up
your Chi
it'll just change this times I sit there
at night and like know how the [ __ ] I
tell you what else I still have from my
cocaine days what's it the 8:00 p.m.
anxiety from 7:45 you go would you get
paranoid you get about 8:20 I get into a
wig well combination of death then NAR
and now I just get into it
I get its self agitating that's a little
effect from my cocaine days because by
8:20 I wanted to know I had it
oh I was gonna get it oh it was on the
way oh it was in my pocket
well for me to rest so till this day
from 7:45 to 8 [ __ ] 20 at night
that's what is struggling an aggravated
like if my wife gets up from the living
room too many times I thought because
you have an open window during that time
you could probably just don't know
that's the only and it's not like I'm
getting up to go get blow that's not
least of my father nothing like that no
nothing like that just it's the old
anxiety I would get ready to sweat the
coat you know I'm not gonna pick up the
coke at that it's New Years
I mean you're it's New Years you're
you're 20 years old right okay you're
eight year nineteen what's doing between
New Year's when you're 19 New Year's we
get 30 you don't start drinking at 2:00
in the afternoon my you know messiaen so
it's like you know how I would start
getting excited about cocaine a
correlate once I knew we picked that up
from Pablo the Ramos family store unless
he gets hits blindsided by a truck oh
I'm getting my cocaine
that's it my sweaty partners wouldn't be
no more I get the shower happy I'd watch
my balls good because I have my package
Rumple my ex and anxiety yeah do you
write everyday about your your progress
well you know I don't stand you
journaling don't do that
I just think it's time table maybe I
should I hate the Janome I look like you
know J Lo's jeopardy contestants you
know I just draw like that you know I
can tell it's just AI type it out don't
you don't even type without write it
with your hand like in the sixth grade
all right today is my [ __ ] tear
cocaine today you met almost warriors
yes it's been two years yes it's our
last encounter yes I like it you're it
there's no line in you there right
can't say that the rest of your
organization okay
talking about Omar Suarez you really
kind of compressed
okay yeah so what a little Scarface
action oh yeah you're not allowed to
watch Scarface either you can't watch
Scarface
can i watch Carlito's Way they're right
words you might go over because you
might go off the [ __ ] Beat Band with
Tony see not even a lot those standing
next to people with white suits on
Oh God saying you never know you might
get a flashback from Vietnam yeah you
know heat me posted I want you on this
show every six weeks okay man if you
relapse you let us know because you're
our own little human experiment right oh
man our goal in the church is to keep
Pablo sober there you go so from now and
every time you do a show they'll be a
church representative they're reporting
back to me yes that's what they usually
do they report back to me watch Eddie
does have some spice I have tons of
spies and they report back to me this
witness your atomic so come watch Amy
I'll come watch us go you [ __ ] get a
urine test after this show I'll bring
your intestine you still got Pablo
Francisco
what is it calm yep calm Pablo Francisco
calm you go to my Twitter Pablo
underscore Francisco check me out come
check me out on tario improv this week -
it's gonna be fun
Thursday through Saturday yeah you do
Sundays - you do Sunday's - we got two
shows on it we have one on Thursday -
one Friday two on Saturday one on Sunday
you've always been a beat mm when they
start cancellation and Irvine they gave
you and I think I caught two of those
feature actually you know it's
tremendous it's fun like you work with
Pablo and I running in not for nothing
well we just did last month yeah
memories what they [ __ ] love that was
98 Wow that seems like yesterday man it
was just it was just a name in 121
[ __ ] years you were a kid Pablo still
got the 280zx to the game you weren't
but I still love you
man old man you set it up to 80 still
got the two years 280zx is 81 and I
still got that bad boy rebuilt the
engine looking sweet you drive it
yes I do but I know today full-time no
not full-time just you know sometimes in
Melrose and you know take it back but
who's my pizza my pizza car you know so
uh
looking good runs great go here right to
to New York in no time
so he's all good man it's ok keep
telling yourself that
right on brother I'll get to New York
you'll break down in Kansas City
don't you cry and what am I gonna do you
know and then you're done once you break
down in Kansas City all you need to see
a black guy with that look in his eye
there you go man you end up in the
[ __ ] crack Haven and when a rock who
you want to add to it you gotta look at
things from the bright side time to time
you ever say don't forget to go see my
man Pablo over or not hey pop yeah Pablo
over in the Ontario improv this weekend
me I got dick I got the Omaha funny bone
the 9th and the 10th the [ __ ]
November and then we got Miami
Thanksgiving weekend the 29th and 30th
there's still tickets left for the
second show at Town Hall New York so
that's it for the year you [ __ ]
a [ __ ] if you don't come see me in
either Omaha Nebraska I don't know how
far my is out of your way the other
place the Miami improv Thanksgiving
weekend or the Town Hall in New York
City go get you tickets but before we go
anywhere I got talk these people buy
something like I told you before the the
show started that you know sometimes I
run heavy and I gotta tell you something
the thing that covers me the most the
thing that's made a big difference
it's CBD line and I use the tension
under my tongue at night before I go to
sleep I sleep better I don't get up last
night I went to bed at 12 I got a
[ __ ] accordin 8 and I haven't gotten
up at all all night I slept steady and
that CBD line whether it's detention I
go with those raspberry gummies any of
the gum peas whether it's a strawberry
the raspberry the arms they're [ __ ]
delicious you know love them do me a
favor
listen go to their website they got
third-party test lab results so you know
what you getting this isn't some [ __ ]
liquor sports abt
or this is own you get CBD you can check
cashing place this is the real deal
Holyfield in that from your uncle Joey
so go to see me they lie
dot-com right now I'm pressing church
and get 20% off your first oil also
[ __ ]
I don't know how what else to tell you
listen if you found the yardstick on the
street you pick it up or would you keep
walking like the MOOC that you are you'd
pick it up so why do you keep picking
winners and you're not [ __ ] betting
on them you had a feeling Houston was
gonna come back you knew it but you
don't got the [ __ ] balls that's why I
go to my bookie it's fast it's easy and
they pay when you win I mean let's face
it where your betting is just as
important is who you're bettin on if
you're trying to bet on the NFL baseball
MMA whatever my bookies got it I
wouldn't be telling you guys to bet with
them if they weren't the best I'll do
the smart thing if you're gonna get best
football our basketball season which is
right now back with my bookie did you
know you can still bet on games after
they [ __ ] start listen if you're the
type of guy or woman that likes to bet a
little or win a lot
try a parlay if at all your picks come
true you'll multiply your winnings
that's what I'm trying to tell you no
matter how you bet the NFL season that's
that time of the year you got NBA NFL
College [ __ ] NHL UFC you got this
weekend Diaz versus Myles devar you got
you know you got a bunch of [ __ ] you can
this is it
my bookie dot AG right now today [ __ ]
start your account with the deposit
they're gonna double your first deposit
use promo code Church CH you are CH to
get a 100% bonus on your initial deposit
up to $1,000 who the [ __ ] is gonna do
that for you
my bookie dot AG today right now go to
my bookie dot AG and don't forget to use
promo code Church why cuz you play you
win you get [ __ ] paid that's my
bookie my B oh okay i e dot AG grab that
[ __ ] pen
my bookie you play you win you get paid
listen let me tell you something we're
living in a society that everybody's
trying to get healthy
if you want to get healthy you could
start with this ready grab a pen
athletic greens you like Joey what's
athletic greens it's an awesome
supplement that gives you a big big
swing and energy all day long if you're
not starting your day off with a blast
of vitamins you already lost a war go
back to bed why are you bothering people
your bad attitude but if you want to
feel tip-top Magoo let athletic greens
do the dirty work you like Joey what
time to let eat greens in one scoop you
get 75 essential vitamins minerals
prebiotics probiotics digestive enzymes
Ross super foods mushrooms the Whole
Foods they got everything no more pill
bottles are trying to choke down a dozen
apples it's all in there the best part
the powder comes in an easy-to-use
Travel Pack I love disguise when I'm on
the road you throw them in my bag just
like the ones Pablo sent me I know I'll
be protected you drink athletic greens
it's like a daily insurance policy
between you and your body I drink this
then I have a little fun you guys see me
onstage you like what do you get the
other gym 57 athletic greens and you can
relax because their ingredients are all
plant-based if you're on keto or
gluten-free you could take this no
chemicals no artificial flavors no
artificial preservatives no sweeteners
no added sugars no GMOs no herbicides
pesticides wheat and all these nothing
week this week dairy gluten corn lactose
you name it they don't got it no animal
products no eggs no yeast no peanuts
guys you need to take care of yourself
and that's why I recommend supplements
everybody it's easy just add cold water
and shake it up that's it you can take
that banana and shove it up your [ __ ]
ass what are you waiting for
athletic greens listen the church family
today gets a special offer right 20 free
travel packs valued at $79 with your
first purchase that's it
jump over that let it greens grab a pen
a th let2 I see greens.com
Church
that's it get your travel packs today
that's athletic greens calm slash shirt
athletic greens [ __ ] tremendous and
when you take a [ __ ]
you're gonna see what I'm talking about
I wanna thank my bookie
I want to thank athletic greens out so I
want to thank CBD line comm for being
the animals that they are and I want to
thank my brother Pablo Francisco for
coming in and rocking this [ __ ]
I don't forget to set your DVRs for
Wednesday I'm gonna be on David Spade
Show Wednesday night tape it live it
[ __ ] love it if I don't see you know
maja I'll see you in Miami
stay black have a great [ __ ] Tuesday
and tell them all to suck your dick
uncle Joey sent you kick this [ __ ]
mealy